[Music]
in our special series school matters
we're looking at the debates
over how to reopen schools safely this
morning we're focusing on the concerns
of parents
more than 56 million students will
attend elementary
middle or high school this fall either
remotely or
in person in more than thirteen thousand
school districts
what that looks like varies leaving
families with endless questions
and worries i will be sending my
12 and 14 year old daughters to school i
will not be sending my six-year-olds to
school
and my four-year-old will continue to go
to daycare we do have a 12-year-old
autistic daughter who is entering the
sixth grade this year
i have two daughters age eight and
seventeen my eldest will be going fully
online the high schooler and for our
youngest
she will also be remote my husband and i
have always provided after school care
for our grandchildren
our granddaughter age 12 enters seventh
grade this year
while her brother age eight goes into
the third grade
how can we be sure that a vaccine will
provide long-standing immunity to this
disease
thus when can our society get back to
normal all my babies can go back to
school
how do the school districts ensure
that children with disabilities are
being kept safe
i know that my child when she's having a
meltdown
does not comprehend social distancing
with increased exposure risks as we keep
the children
after school how can we make sure that
we
as their grandparents can stay safe so
we're worried about
equity making sure all the kids get what
they need equitably that means
food that means education that means
being able to get everything that they
need this school year
in a safe manner